I love this question because I just
wanted to say am I the first speak who
was like not speaking English first
language
maybe I'm as an immigrant masa anybody
else here so all about inclusion like
equity about non Morningside that's
that's what I also brought my slide this
going to help me and so I'm going to
read a little bit off perhaps but I'm
here to share a very personal story
about how art helped me to communicate
science better and made me a better
science educator so my name is Christina
Ricci I'm from Cold Spring Harbor
Laboratory and I'm a science educator
and trained geneticist I live in York
City since a couple of years and as part
of my work I develop whole frameworks
which student-centered citizen science
by diversity research so it's all about
from science praying how to break this
down bring this to other audiences and
students but it's actually no training
scientists to be I'm like training and
general audience to be to be a scientist
so I direct to citizen science programs
that have been replicated worldwide and
I see my role is like bridging science
society by bringing the signs to
unlikely places for example I also
proudly wear my science pins I don't
know Christine lieu she's in the
audience this pin you know that we all
have and God you know science for
everybody I really like to wear my
science pin and and create some stories
around this because a lot of people
approached me on the subway hey what is
this night and stuff like hey this is
day and universal influence of influenza
vaccine and do you believe in vaccines
and all those things so it's it's just
really fun for me to do to create this
one but more recently I explored you
know art is a soft way of scientific
inquiries I don't know how to get to the
next slide here they allowed me to have
one slide and take advantage of that one
I just like pin down here or thank you
so much okay so I want to tell you a
very personal story about how I learned
you know to use art especially by your
art as a meaning of soft scientific
storytelling I say it's a soft because
I'm so trained in hard science data data
data the beautiful graph is what's going
to intrigue me you know but it all
started off when I was approached by a
by the company actually
Austria's I'm Austrian native and they
were looking for a person who can do and
hands-on activity or maybe an artwork a
3d artwork about infectious disease and
this is the big face and nose you see
Anna top-left the Vienna Science
Festival so I designed together as an
artist face you can open the left side
was regular you see Anatomy on the right
side actually had velcro and we had like
a lot of attendees coming in and just
like bombard to velcro his little
globular balls we should be the viruses
so he actually brought an activity
together with you know what kind of face
that is and it just really helped me to
communicate science it also helped me to
get to people it actually would
otherwise not show up so it was a
science festival that was actually in
and middle of a street art fair and you
got like so many people coming over and
just doing these activities we have one
of the most popular ones because I don't
know I don't have students I mean I
don't have kids and I have been working
with students but students are never and
kids are never going to show up to a
fair and see what can I see they always
can ask you what can I do and the
feedback that we got in Vienna there's
not much hands-on science we have one
location but every time we go to a
science fair it's kind of a crafty
Church is really really like this one
and my highlight was when I actually had
a diversity party coming over they just
saw this and then they just totally
wanted to be scientists and be the virus
affecting us so this was one thing then
coming back to New York I realized
actually there are a lot of meetups of
people outside of science that are
intrigued by biological systems so I was
parked a core working crew but it was
cold notes in networks New York City
that bahattar Barnett she's a she's a
science communicator an artist in London
with on the laser and she brought people
together to actually explore the city as
a superorganism which was really
fascinating because you know she brought
architects together science
communicators the people from the Met
media different museums and you know we
played around with our Garvey's like be
structures with exploring you know
microbes it was just really fun and then
highlight was to actually ask people to
to play out and actually
biological systems in public spaces like
the park and they're also like you know
just this collision between art and
science and people being creative just
really there was a really nice overlap
for me to learn how to communicate my
science better and that was really what
helped me in the next project I was
approached by people from John space and
there was the open coffin in a new
museum idea city festival and their call
for that year was the invisible City and
at this time it was also this paper by
Chris Mason right across the street
about the New York City subway swabbing
you know where they claimed you kind of
can fit all microbes or electronic city
and people kind of like afraid so you
use this as a platform to invite people
from the general public to actually
paint a collective artwork using live
microbes and make a painting of New York
City so but what we did is we did not
only go to a street festival we totally
stripped the whole project from
scientific lingo so we framed it as an
art crafty experience we had scientists
and artists working together which is
really interesting because I'm a
scientist I wanted to get the science
right they wanted to get art right and
in the little space the gray area
between you know you're gonna listen to
the other side but like what other
people said just before me this is when
you know the real interaction is going
to happen this is how we can just like
you know work together so you brought
this out there and it was just really it
was just really nice to see you know how
people could show up don't know that it
gonna talk about science and designs in
a couple of seconds we told them this is
an invisible paint you are gonna get
laughs um because you have some live
microbes in there which was the first
question oh my god I thought they're
only bad so just talking about what
people are afraid of by exposing them to
well be a move away from the germ theory
of disease you can just use this you
know to make something really beautiful
like in artwork which is living and
breathing so that was really one one
thing that really touched me so the New
York City bio map was the later on some
meta two days
a darf competition and I don't know if
the if the ESM represents our here maybe
you can talk to her later on exactly so
I'm between second prize that year and
the picture really sucking to a lot of
people hats and you can maybe talk to
him later on it really helped them to
find a segue how to speak to people from
community labs and to bring this
hands-on activity and also this way to
talk about microbes and microbiology to
people are actually made it might be
intimidated by a going to a classic
institution like I'm from Cold Spring
Harbor a lot of people don't want to
talk to me because I represent an
institution so working as a community
lab is actually different and the second
thing is also to find a way to speak to
people that might otherwise be
intimidated by science and find another
way into you know to do some really
really nice science outreach so because
this activity was successful I figured
okay maybe we should actually take to
service out one of our programs at a DNA
Learning Center and because we really
did something always which is focused
and zoomed in on DNA but why not play
some play around with something crafty
so we opened our space for overall
series of Saturday's and we had like the
house full I've never seen any risks
like anything so successful like this
before
artworks that have been created in my
workshop they also like won the art
contest again and again which is also
like really interesting for me to see
like this hidden creativity and and the
butterfly down there it was done by a
ten year old student so she she was like
totally great so the lesson that I found
out about this one you know when you are
I know I've been working in science
education since 12f years okay and I
think I can go out there and talk to
people about science and a lot of
science and people feel like see I don't
really passionate about this one but you
really have to go out there one day and
just try to find an area where you're
going to struggle and now we all know it
but we don't do it and just like talking
to artists it was not easy believe me
and it really taught me stopping being
such a scientist and sometimes go out of
my signs
brain and go into people's hearts so
doing art helped me to let art do the
talking because a picture speaks to you
more intuitively and you're more
interesting than me like lecturing you
about you know microbes and I don't know
piet mondrian you know like probably
boogie woogie and be using reductionist
approach I have two waterways and all
these things you just use this like you
know a tracing of your eyes but just
like jumping up and down so no forget
about this like a picture is just going
to draw people in differently and that's
that's actually really helped me to to
be a better science educator and talk
about you know reach people that they
are actually going to talk about the
fears on another level so that's what I
wanted to share hopefully does my sense
and I'm happy to take any questions more
of a comment because steam of course is
becoming a thing I didn't mention Steven
yes it's a steam activity
yeah and listening recently didn't made
Jemison the an astronaut she was a
dancer her whole that is a dancer and
just how the creativity of the art form
informed her work as a researcher and
those things are not opposite or
separate they are they were necessary
together I I do see it as complementary
as well and I'm very inspired by Eric
Kandel who brought two wonderful books
about art and science and I met him
recently and you know he says you know
we just keep doing this he saw this
picture he said you just keep doing this
well you know this is ours I did this
all in my free time by the way this is
my little side project but maybe I
should just like doing more of this
never free time is science education
you